you guys have done a really good job of
putting in that position one of the
questions that I got from people when I
asked on Twitter before we did this was
what is something that you believed in
the early days that you have softened
your stance on so something that you
believe you know very strongly and now
either maybe have changed your mind or
softened your stance well I was and many
people often forget this but I was
actually a big blocker back in the day I
I thought that you know one of the
premises of Bitcoin should be that
transactions should be cheap and it
wasn't until I actually started working
in the space and started having to run a
lot of Bitcoin nodes that were then
being used by infrastructure that I
realized it's not just about the current
transaction throughput it is about the
aggregate you know amount of data that
the entire blockchain is storing and if
you allow that to accelerate then it
becomes you know geometrically if not
exponentially more difficult for a
newcomer to come in and validate the
entire history and be able to set up
their own node and infrastructure so one
of the the issues that I ended up having
was with people who were only focused on
you know what is the hardware that is
capable with you know keeping up with
the current volume of transaction like
how many transactions per second can we
do that the hardware can keep up with
basically nobody was ever thinking about
well yeah but how long does it take to
sink from scratch and so you know that's
actually one of the projects that I do
on an annual basis is I resync a whole
bunch of nodes not only for Bitcoin but
also for other popular networks just to
compare to see like which ones are
becoming easier to audit and which ones
are becoming more difficult to audit
speaking of other chains there was I
think every [ __ ] coiner and every
intellectually honest person in the
comments of my question asking we know
that he's very
and has a deep-seated belief in Bitcoin
is there any other projects in this
space that either one you're curious
about think are interesting or maybe
even or a kind of a big believer
yeah so I am I'm interested in anything
that promises better privacy so I'm
interested in things like Manero Z cash
grin you know any in insanely out there
knew cryptographic primitives that
people are playing around with these are
often far too experimental for us to
imagine them being brought onto Bitcoin
anytime soon but I would say that the
thing that I find least interesting are
the the various networks that claim to
be like infinitely scalable with free
transactions I think that that is not
being intellectually honest because
someone has to pay for it ultimately
it's the infrastructure providers
ultimately you end up you know
centralizing around a smaller and
smaller number of them I think a good
example of that would probably be a OS
which I believe only has like a few
dozen validators and I actually tried to
set up an EOS validator just to see and
like it was too difficult even for my
beefy machine so it's interesting to see
the trade-offs that certain people are
willing to make and you know even if you
only have a few dozen nodes or whatever
on the network you know you can run it
it'll it'll probably be fine but the the
trade-offs are not something that I
think the majority if people are going
to be willing to accept for sure